>> THE AMAZON ECHO HAS HELPED
MILLIONS WITH THEIR DAILY
ROUTINE.
>> ALEXA, WHAT TIME IS IT?
WHAT THE HELL IS WRONG WITH THIS
BLASTED THING?
AMANDA --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> BUT, THE LATEST TECHNOLOGY
ISN'T ALWAYS EASY TO USE FOR
PEOPLE OF A CERTAIN AGE.
>> THESE KIDS BOUGHT ME A BUSTED
MACHINE AGAIN.
ODESSA!
>> THAT'S WHY AMAZON PARTNERED
WITH AARP TO PRESENT THE NEW
AMAZON ECHO SILVER.
THE ONLY SMART SPEAKER DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY TO BE USED BY THE
GREATEST GENERATION.
IT'S SUPER LOUD, AND RESPONDS TO
ANY NAME EVEN REMOTELY CLOSE TO
ALEXA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO THEY CAN FIND OUT THE
WEATHER.
>> ALLEGRA WHAT IS THE WEATHER
OUTSIDE?
>> IT IS 74 DEGREES AND SUNNY.
>> HUH?
>> WHERE?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OUTSIDE.
>> WHAT ABOUT IT?
>> THE TEMPERATURE OUTSIDE IS 74
DEGREES AND SUNNY.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THE LATEST IN SPORTS.
>> COLLESSA, HOW MANY DID
SATCHEL PAGE STRIKE OUT LAST
NIGHT?
>> SATCHEL PAGE DIED IN 1982.
>> HOW MANY DID HE GET?
>> SATCHEL PAGE IS DEAD.
>> SAY WHAT NOW?
>> DIED.
>> WHO DID?
>> SATCHEL PAGE.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
>> EVEN LOCAL NEWS, AND POP
CULTURE.
>> ANITA.
WHAT THEM BOYS UP TO ACROSS THE
STREET.
>> THEY ARE JUST PLAYING.
>> THEY'RE WHAT NOW?
>> YOU SAY THEY'RE JUST PLAYING
NOW?
>> YES, THEY ARE JUST PLAYING.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
>> CONTROL DEVICES LIKE YOUR
THERMOSTAT.
>> ALEXANDRA TURN THE HEAT UP.
>> THE ROOM IS ALREADY 100
DEGREES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ARE YOU'RE TRYING TO KILL ME,
ALEXANDRA.
>> THE NEW AMAZON ECHO SILVER
PLAYS ALL THE MUSIC THEY LOVED
WHEN THEY WERE YOUNG.
>> ANGELA, PLAY BLACK JAZZ.
>> PLAYING THE JAZZ.
♪♪♪
>> IT ALSO HAS A QUICK SCAN
FEATURE TO HELP THEM FIND
THINGS.
>> AMELIA, WHERE DID I PUT THE
PHONE.
>> THE PHONE IS IN YOUR RIGHT
HAND.
>> AND IT HAS AN UH-HUH FEATURE
FOR LONG RAMBLING STORIES.
>> BUT THEN I GAVE HIM FIVE
DOLLARS.
IN HIS HEAD I ONLY GAVE HIM ONE
DOLLAR.
>> UH-HUH.
>> I SAID I KNOW I GAVE YOU A
FIVE.
>> UH-HUH.
>> CAUSE I ONLY HAD A 5 AND A
1 ON ME.
>> UH-HUH.
>> AND THERE'S THE $1 RIGHT
HERE.
>> UH-HUH.
>> SO, I MEAN YOU TELL ME WHO IS
CRAZY.
>> AMAZON ECHO SILVER.
GET YOURS TODAY.
I SAID GET YOURS TODAY!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
TO ORDER AMAZON ECHO SILVER,
SEND A CHECK OR MONEY ORDER TO
AMAZON.COM RIGHT NOW.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪